Ukraine says its troops have encircled
Russian forces in a key Eastern Town
Limon has been under Russian control
since the spring Ukraine's military says
that thousands of Russian troops there
are now surrounded President Vladimir
zielinski's Chief of Staff posted this
video on Twitter it's set to show
Ukrainian troops raising the Ukrainian
flag on the outskirts of the town
the Iman is in the Donetsk region one of
four that Russian President Vladimir
Putin proclaimed to be part of Russia on
Friday Ukraine's president zielinski has
condemned the illegal annexation and
vowed to keep fighting to regain lost
territory
we have achieved significant results in
the east of our country there is already
enough information out there about this
everyone has heard about what is
happening in liman in the Donetsk region
this means a lot to us
and our correspondent Nick Connelly
joins us now from the Ukrainian Capital
Kiev hello to you Nick so as we've been
talking about Ukraine's military says it
has encircled Russian troops in liman
what's the latest you can tell us about
the fighting there
well this is a very important town
indeed this is a kind of strategic part
of the donbass region it's the
Northwestern Corner uh as the Ukraine
would say at the beginning of their
retaking territory that Russia has
basically spent a lot of energy lots of
lives and lots of tech taking over the
past few months and it seems like those
Russian troops are indeed now surrounded
there is or at least there was at last
checking one route out albeit one route
out that was under a threat of artillery
fire from the ukrainians so there was
basically the option for those Russian
troops stuck there of which by different
accounts are about 5 000 some people say
as many as 10 000 either to stay there
to fight potentially to their deaths or
to hand themselves over as prisons of
water the ukrainians or to try and get
out but with that significant risk of
being hit by artillery fire or from the
ukrainians and this is really really
obviously important especially for you
know Ukraine's president zielinski a day
after that big event in Moscow those
illegal annexations being uh you know
announced to the world with a lot of
fanfare there a sense and you know
showing the world that Ukraine is taking
this territory back this territory that
Russia claims is its own and that you
know as much as Lena Putin can claim uh
that this is irreversible that these
parts of Ukraine are now Russian Forever
on the ground for now Ukrainian troops
are making significant inroads and
pushing those Russian troops back
right and there's also you a Ukrainian
offensive underway in
well that's the thing all summer you
heard the Ukrainian military top brass
top officials talking about the south
about her son how important it was that
this was going to be the big focus and
then in the end we saw actually compared
to little happening there and all the
focus being in region where they took
the Russians basically by surprise and
pushed them back uh in the space of a
week Ukraine picked up as much territory
as Russia had gained in the previous
five months in a week now the progress
is a lot smaller it's a lot slower but
the Russians are in a very vulnerable
situation because they're basically on
the Left Bank of the emperor River and
all the ways across it the bridges have
been destroyed so they're dependent on
ferries and pontoon bridges to try and
bring supplies in so there is the
expectation that the Ukraine's will make
a move but again we've been proved wrong
so many times all the military analysts
have been blindsided by what Ukraine's
Army did in the end I think it's a very
brave analyst pundit now who you know
says where the Ukrainian Army is going
to go next
well Nick we are getting reports of
another Russian attack on a civilian
evacuation Convoy what more can you tell
us about that
so we've heard from the Ukraine
officials in the region just in the past
few hours they talk about six cars that
were destroyed had been shot at and
burnt out with civilians inside dead
including a child they don't yet know
when this happened this happened
basically in the gray zone between
Ukrainian and Russian front lines just
east of kupians which is in the kharkiv
region towards the border with lohansk
region we were there about a week ago
and you know that Gray Zone that is a
real thing even the people on the ground
the soldiers don't necessarily know you
know if it's Friendly Fire or the other
side coming at them we were in that town
and suddenly there's a helicopter above
us and everyone assumed it was a
Ukrainian helicopter until it started
firing at the Ukrainian positions so
there are lots of bits of territory
where civilians are in a really really
difficult position because they just
don't know where to go for safety where
to how to get out and where which troops
are and I think unfortunately as this
goes on there's going to be a lot more
of these kinds of losses of life before
this is over
DW's Nick Connelly in Kiev Nick thank
you we appreciate it
well Western allies have responded to
moscow's Illegal annexations of four
Ukrainian regions with yet more
sanctions targeting Russian individuals
and companies meanwhile the White House
National Security adviser says another
delivery of weapons to Ukraine is coming
soon President Joe Biden said the U.S
and NATO would not be intimidated by
Vladimir Putin
America is fully prepared with our NATO
allies to defend every single inch of
NATO territory
every single inch so Mr Putin don't
misunderstand what I'm saying every inch
the U.S president speaking there but now
we can speak to Michael baranovsky he is
a senior fellow at the German Marshall
fund and an expert on defense and
Eastern Europe Mr butanovsky welcome to
DW so as we've been hearing Ukrainian
forces are now on the offensive around
Limon how is Vladimir Putin likely to
respond now that his troops are
essentially being pushed out of what
he's calling Russian territory
well Putin is responding in a way that
we are seeing on TV uh he's trying to
freeze the front uh freeze the line of
contact where it is right now he is not
able to push back on Ukrainian forces
with its own military therefore He
restored to this
sham referendums uh in trying to put up
political barrier uh backed up by his
nuclear threats so it we don't know what
he will do next except that Russia
continues to lose
conventionally in Ukraine and that will
continue to be the case
well we should of course remember that
these four annexed regions are in fact
not fully under Russian control so what
has Putin gained from announcing these
annexations
well the worst case scenario so to say
uh the the negative explanation of this
is that putting switched the direction
of the war so to say we all know that
this is a war of aggression it's Russia
it's Putin's forces that crossed into
Ukraine by claiming that these four
regions are part of Russia he's trying
to reverse this logic to say that it's
ukrainians who are somehow invading the
territory of Russia and and this way he
motivates his military his Society for a
defensive rather than offensive War so
he is definitely rushing up the the
escalation pressure on on Ukraine and
the West
so does this mean that these annexations
essentially make a negotiated settlement
or some sort of negotiated end to this
conflict impossible
for a very long time the we will not see
negotiated settlement of this conflict
also because it is unacceptable right
now to the Ukrainian side as president
zielinski very clearly stated to
negotiate with Putin himself
um it will be
um the line of contact right now cannot
be the negotiated settlement Putin would
have to withdraw from Ukraine and he's
unlikely to do it anytime soon unless
expelled uh militarily and on the other
hand the Ukrainian government even if
they wanted to cannot accept the line
between the four regions and the rest of
Ukraine because the Ukrainian Society is
not going to allow this Ukraine is
winning uh and and Putin is trying to
put up this fake political lines
political barrier in order to basically
freeze the war where it is right now and
have this protracted Conflict for many
months and perhaps years to come
that was Michael baranowsky senior
fellow at the German Marshall fund thank
you so much for your insights
thank you